-You're a stud.
Yeah, number one.
Not too shabby, huh?
Congrats.
You wear number one
pretty well, bud.
Yeah.
-Thank you. Thanks. Yeah.
It's nice.
My first New York --
It's my first
number one anything.
-Is it really?
-Yeah.
-Before we talk
about "The Watcher,"
we had your fantastic spouse,
Rose Byrne...
-Yeah, yeah.
-...on the show two nights ago.
And she was saying how
into Halloween the family was.
-Oh. It's October, right?
Yeah.
We've been at it since July.
Oh, is that right?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
My kids are just like -- They
wear costumes almost every day.
So Halloween is like
an affirmation for them
that, "This is what we should be
doing all the time."
-Yeah, just wearing costumes
all the time.
What is everyone going as again?
-This year, we're going as Hulk.
-Yeah.
-Rose is Wonder Woman.
Rocco is Darth Vader.
And the other one is --
Rafael is Jafar.
-Jafar?
-Jafar from --
You know, the villain
from "Aladdin."
-Yeah, exactly.
-With the parrot
and the beard and the thing,
yeah.
-I love it.
I love it. That's so --
-We love it.
We love it.
That's -- it really is --
it's their favorite holiday.
And, you know, we -- you know,
we do the pumpkin patches.
We do the corn mazes
and the cannons.
And, you know, we go through,
like, four versions --
four pumpkins that rot
because we've been putting them
out there since August,
you know, just getting ready.
-So you already had
four rotten pumpkins.
Now, finally,
this is the weekend.
-This is finally happening,
so we're really excited.
You were telling me backstage,
by the way,
that you just finished a movie
with Robert De Niro.
-Yeah.
-I worked with De Niro before.
Is it -- It's just amazing
to be next to that guy.
-It is. It is.
But I don't, like --
I don't notice it
when I'm doing it with him,
when I'm acting with him.
I mean, I'm very aware that I'm
working with a very good actor
when we're doing it,
but I don't really --
I don't really take it --
-That it's Robert De Niro?
-I don't make it a big deal
in my head, and it's not,
but it hits me every time,
like, later, when I'm at home.
Like, this last time,
I worked with him
all day one day in a car,
and we were like,
"We've got to do a fight
in the middle of the street."
"You know...you," you know,
screaming at each other,
and then, like,
a big dramatic scene.
And I kept it together all day.
And then I was taking out
the garbage that night
and literally, like,
had to stop --
it all hit me
like a ton of bricks.
I had to sit down.
I was a little emotional
about it.
I was like, "I can't believe
the day I just had,"
like, you know,
if the 10-year-old me
could see
what was happening that day.
-I mean, Robert De Niro.
He's a legend.
-Yeah, he's pretty great.
-I mean,
you're pretty great, too,
but I mean, you guys together.
But I mean, I love that
that's what made you --
You're just taking out the trash
and you're like,
"Wait. Hold on a second."
-Oh.
-"I had the most amazing day."
-I had to sit down.
Like, I was putting
the trash out.
-And go -- and get emotional
and go, "Wow,
I can't believe
I was just acting..."
-Yeah, I was outside
for a long time.
-..."with one of the greatest
actors of all time."
-Yeah.
Robert De Niro.
-Yeah, you gotta, right?
You have to, at some point,
you know, really take it in.
-Take it in.
-I can't do it
while I'm acting with him
or else, you know, I'm dead.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He won't respect you, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, no, no, no.
He's the greatest.
-Let's talk
about "The Watcher."
Congrats on this.
-Thank you.
-As I said, number one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Number one drama series
on Netflix for a while now.
-Ryan Murphy.
-Dude, is it Ryan Murphy?
-Ryan Murphy knows what's up.
-Did you have any idea
it would be this big?
-No.
I mean, no, you can't predict
these things at all.
I mean, I've been in things
that I thought
were going to do better
commercially, and they weren't.
And you just --
you just never know.
You only can tell -- Like, I've
been doing this a long time.
I could tell if something's big
by how I'm treated,
like, at the gym.
You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
Everybody wants to spot me,
you know what I mean?
Like --
-They all know you there.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like, they'll always look --
the eye contact.
And the like -- you know,
people don't bother me too much.
But, like, now, you know,
they're just there.
Like, "That ending, bro."
-[ Laughs ]
-Or they want like --
Yeah, yeah.
-"That ending, bro.
I don't know.
We've got to talk about that."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
People -- People will come
right up to you
and tell you
what they thought of the ending.
-But do you know the story
and hear about the story,
and were you spooked when
you heard even about the story?
-You know what?
I think that story's
really cool.
And, you know,
it's just that one story
in "New York Magazine."
-Yes.
-Is the source of this.
And it's been read
so many times.
So, I think, like --
there's something about it --
I think it's really about fear
and about powerlessness.
And, like, I think the actual
event, to me,
isn't that interesting.
They never found out who did it,
but yet,
people are obsessed with it.
I think they're obsessed
with it
because that feeling
of powerlessness, of being --
having something
taken away from you
and not knowing
who's doing it is frightening.
-It's frightening.
-It's terrifying.
-What would you do
in that situation?
-I was interested in that.
-Would you ever be
in that situation?
-I would never be
in that situation.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, first of all,
I would never live in, like --
I just wouldn't live like that.
I need a lot of people
around me.
I can't live out --
-You mean, like, in a house?
-Yeah. Like, in a house
with a big property.
I like to have --
I like sharing walls.
I do.
I like having --
-Such a New Yorker.
-I believe in
safety in numbers.
I like having a lot of people.
-A lot of people around.
-Yeah, I do.
-Yeah, witnesses.
-City person.
-Yeah, they know
exactly what happened.
-Yeah.
-For people that haven't seen
"The Watcher" yet,
can you set up
for everybody what it's about
and who you play?
-I play -- I play a guy that
runs around the house a lot.
[ Laughter ]
I play -- I play a guy who --
his family, they move in.
They -- you know,
they buy their dream home.
-Aww, that's so cute.
-They -- they put --
they spend all their money that
they've got from this house.
And the moment they move in,
somebody starts sending creepy,
horrible letters to them.
And -- And they're sort of --
And then I do a lot of running
around the house looking scared.
-Yeah, getting letters from
someone called "The Watcher,"
and they're saying,
"I'm watching you."
-Yeah.
-"Just letting you know.
Welcome to the neighborhood."
-Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-"We noticed -- We noticed
that you've got young blood."
I have two children in --
in this thing.
They refer to them
as "young blood."
-Oof.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Bobby Cannavale
in "The Watcher."
Take a look at this.
-I am pleased
to know your names now
and the names of the young blood
you have brought me.
You certainly
say their names often.
Ellie, Carter.
Ellie is a lovely pianist
with delicate fingers.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Door opens ]
657 Boulevard
is happy you're here.
♪♪
It's been years
since young blood
ruled the hallways
of the house.
Have you found all
the secrets it holds in it?
Will the young blood
play in the basement,
or are they too afraid
to go down there alone?
I would be very afraid,
if I were them.
It is far away
from the rest of the house.
If you were upstairs, you would
never hear them scream.
-What's going on?
-"What is going on?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bobby Cannavale, everybody.
"The Watcher" is on Netflix
right now.
Congrats, buddy.
-Thanks, buddy.
-Couldn't happen to
a better guy.